- All right. Jennell?
Jennell.
Where'd you grow up? Where
are you from, originally?
- Seward, Alaska.
- Alaska?
- Yup.
- And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents as a kid?
- Um, well, not really.
I had my mom and my grandparents.
My dad was out of the picture
by the time I was six.
- How would you describe your childhood?
- My childhood was really good.
I was raised with horses
and I did a lot of dancing
and gymnastics and swimming.
And then my mom met my stepdad
and pulled us away from all of that
and moved us to Anchorage.
And I did not like that.
I didn't like that at all.
And I left home at 13,
after that.
We did some ballroom dancing before that
you know, ballroom and
Latin dancing and stuff.
And it wasn't my thing.
- So what was going on that
made you leave home at 13?
- I was really upset they
took me away from my horses,
in Fairbanks.
So, then I got into the drugs
with all the kids at school,
you know, started with pot and then acid.
Then I left home with my boyfriend
and that's when everything
went really bad.
- How was growing up in Alaska? Is it--
- Cold.
Really cold?
- I'm sure it's cold, but is it?
Are there, are drugs
pretty common down there?
- That's all there is to do.
That's all there is to do.
There's nothing else to do.
- Mm.
- So--
- And your boyfriend went where?
- Oh, on the street.
His mom was a, um,
a crack whore
and she real quickly turned me out.
So by the time I was 13
I was prostituting
and using crack cocaine.
- Mm.
- And then from there I was,
I prostituted 'til I was 21.
And then,
on and off the streets
and, I don't know,
life, life has just been hard.
Like when I was eight, I was
molested by my Camp Counselor.
And,
I don't remember that though.
I've just been told about it
but I guess it was pretty bad,
but, um,
I don't know, I've just
been on and off the streets
since, since then.
- Did you finish school?
- No.
- How far did you go?
- Eighth, ninth grade.
Two weeks into my ninth grade year.
- And today your how old?
- I'm 44.
- 44.
Do you have kids?
- Yeah. I have three daughters.
- And where are they?
- They're in Fairbanks.
- Who's raising them?
- They're all grown, all
except for my youngest.
She's 15.
Her dad has her.
- And so did you raise your kids?
- Um, no.
No. My two oldest were
raised by my grandparents
and
my mom
and my youngest was
between me and her dad.
- So prostitution was the
way you were surviving
for--
- For a long time.
- For a long time?
- I still do once in a while. Yeah.
- Yeah. So today you're in Skid Row?
- Yeah.
- And how? You're still
using drugs, I take it?
- Yeah.
- What's your drug today?
- Heroin.
- And this is rough life as well, right?
- Oh, yeah, too rough.
- Is it rougher here in
Skid Row than, than--
- No.
- Alaska?
- No. This is way easier, way easier.
- The weather's easy?
- Yeah. It's not 60 below zero.
So this is kinda nice, actually.
It's a nice change.
- And how long have you been here?
- Two weeks.
- Oh, you're brand new?
- Yeah.
- From where?
- From Fairbanks.
- Oh, from Alaska.
- Yeah.
- Oh, wow.
- I had never been out of Alaska until now
- So LA must be a nice, nice breakthrough
- It's a wonderful change.
- It's dangerous here too as well though?
- Yeah.
Yeah.
I've had a couple scares,
but...
- So tell, tell me what
happened between those years.
So in your 30's and 40's,
you were doing what?
- Well I actually was doing okay
in my 30's and 40's
I bought a piece of property
and, um,
owned a home.
It burned down.
- How did you afford to buy a home?
- Um, I only had to pay
8,000 for the property.
So I worked a little
bit with my grandparents
and some other things to make the money
and bought the property, put
a double wide trailer on there
and ended up getting pregnant,
having my daughter.
And three days after
we moved into the home
it burned down with us in it.
And so that was pretty scary,
but we, we got out, thank God,
barely, but we got out
and then we put another trailer up
and,
I have been struggling to survive there
up until now.
And I just, I couldn't do it no more
so I sold the place and left.
- So if you could put
your finger on one thing
that kinda led to your
spiraling downward--
- Drugs.
- Drugs?
- All the way.
- Not, not the molestation
when you were young.
- Oh, that could be it,
I just don't remember it.
I've been told about it by several people.
I've, I've seen the paperwork.
I'm the only one out of
22 kids that testified.
And, um,
I guess it took a couple years.
I remember, I remember the court
going, going to see the
judges and everything.
There was like 12 judges around the table
that I had to sit there in front of
with a doll and tell them what happened.
I don't remember what I told them.
I do remember leaving.
And my lawyer gave me a kitten
but that's about all I remember of that.
- A horrible thing.
- Yeah. The paperwork
said it was pretty bad
mm, it was really bad.
- And do you still have
contact with your family?
- Yeah.
- Your kids?
- Yeah. My middle daughter
doesn't like me too much
but,
my other kids like me all right.
- And wait, what's the worst
part of this lifestyle for you?
Living on the street,
drugs, prostitution, all that.
- Not being with my kids.
- Yeah.
- Having to struggle all the time.
- Did you have dreams as a kid
of doing something with your life?
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah. I wanted to be, I
don't want it to be anything.
I thought I was gonna be a
professional horseback rider
you know, just horses and stuff like that.
But it didn't go that way.
- Yeah.
And do you have friends?
- Oh yeah.
I've got lots of friends,
but none of them any good.
- You ever been in love?
- Oh, yeah. Too many times.
In fact, I'm trying to
I guess I'm in a
relationship still Fairbanks
kind of, he thinks I'm coming back.
I'm not,
so
that's hard.
That's really hard.
- And what do you worry about?
- What do I worry about?
Surviving another day?
It's hard out here.
- Do you see that the
family you grew up in
might've
set the path for this
all that happened?
Or your family was pretty solid?
- Well, they were, when I was younger
and then they got really weird
and everything just really fell apart
when my mom took us away
from my grandparents
and fell apart really bad.
My grandparents really turned out to be
not who they were.
I mean, they're mean, they're
extremely mean and nasty now
to the grandkids.
- Some, something must've
been off for a 13 year old
to go out in the street.
- Yeah.
- And not finish school.
- I absolutely hated the fact
that my mom took me away from my horses.
I hated her for that.
I still do.
I don't hate her for it, but
I definitely am still pissed.
- And how do you feel all
these years on the street
and doing questionable things for money
has changed you?
- It's turned me into a
lot harder of a person.
I'm not nearly as nice
as I probably could be.
I don't trust anybody anymore.
- Trust, trust must be a big issue, right?
- Yeah.
It's a huge issue.
- So you think everyone
down here is a snake?
- Yeah.
I get sick of being groped constantly
by the men down here, you know,
it's irritating.
- Right.
But you still have hope for your future?
- Not really.
Now I'm pretty much guessing
this is about how it's gonna be.
I don't see much else happening.
I'm a little too old to
come up at all
I feel, I don't see any big
sums of money happening,
you know? So--
- What, what was your lowest point?
- My lowest point?
It's probably right now.
Being down here with absolutely nothing.
No car,
no home.
Just my sister.
It's hard.
No money,
no food,
no nothing.
- And what's the most important
lesson you've learned?
- Stay the fuck away from drugs.
I wish I could get away from them.
I hate 'em.
- Tell me about Alaska.
I mean, it seems like
that must be a, a rough--
- It's cold there.
It's really, really cold.
If you don't have a place
to live, you're screwed.
There's no way you can
live on the streets there.
You have to either couch
hop or go to a shelter.
If there's an available bed,
if not you're living in your car
and you better hope you have gas,
'cause if not you're gonna freeze to death
in the winter anyway.
- Lit, literally?
- Yeah. Literally.
- Yeah.
- 60 below zero is no joke.
- What, what do you think was the,
the, the basis of your mom's,
what you think, do you
do you see your mom is just being selfish
in taking you away from what you loved?
- Well, she was addicted
to drugs really bad
when I was younger.
- Oh, she was an addict as well?
- Yeah. And then she got
clean and met my stepdad
and my stepdad swept her off her feet
and he what he said went and
he wanted to move to Anchorage.
And so that's what we did.
And I wasn't very happy with that at all.
- Yeah.
And heroin down here,
I mean, the quality of it is
probably questionable. Right?
- It's not very good.
now I have to say the stuff
in Fairbanks is better
by far,
which is strange.
I thought it would be better here.
It's not though.
Not at all.
- And where do you see your life going?
I mean, you've already mentioned
that maybe you're stuck
in this will be it.
- Yeah. I hope not.
I mean, I, I'm hoping
I'm hoping I just got
accepted for the unemployment
so I'm hoping maybe I can get an apartment
or something like that, but I don't know.
And then maybe find a job.
I don't know,
with this COVID thing, who knows?
- Yeah.
- It's kinda screwing everything up.
- And is, does that affect your work
if you're dating guys that must--
- Big time,
big time.
- 'Cause you fear potential
clients out there?
- Yeah. Then a lot of
calls quit coming in.
And there's a lot of
people that are scared.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah. Not very much
money in it right now.
- Yeah. Everyone's scrambling for
a buck right now.
- Yeah.
- All right, Jannell,
well thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Yeah.
- And I wish you the best of luck.
- Thank you.
- Welcome to LA.
- Thanks.
- Welcome to hell.
- Yeah.
- We're in Skid Row's.
- Yeah, it definitely is.